how's it going everyone it's warren and
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and now the
multiverse it does appear that the
multiverse has been introduced in one
division to
the mcu now when one division first
started we didn't really have any idea
what it was going to be about and then
episodes 1 and 2 premiered
and we still didn't really know what it
was about now marvel has recently given
us more answers but with those answers
come
more questions and a lot of us are
wondering what exactly is going on
well i believe i have discovered what is
actually going on
with wandavision all the way down to the
finale and in case i'm right about this
i have to issue a spoiler warning
just in case i might actually guess and
predict what the finale will be like
and how this all happened in one
division and who is involved and
responsible
now this theory today is backed by five
main points that are based on actual
evidence that marvel has provided us
with
or have been proven real by legitimate
leaked photos from
wanda vision so everything i say in this
video
my whole theory is backed up by actual
evidence
so let's dive into this but first if you
love marvel and want to stay up to date
on everything mcu be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
videos
so we'll first start this video off with
my first main point and that is about
agnes i firmly believe that agnes is
agatha harkness or at least a
very powerful witch i think some people
may not know this or have forgotten this
as we've watched one division and again
spoiler warning because i am going to
show some leaked photos
if you recall many many months ago we
got some leaked photos of the supposed
character agnes
however judging by these photos it's
very clear that
agnes is a witch this would confirm what
we thought for a very long time
agnes is just a shortened name of agatha
harkness and it's very important to not
forget this
as we're watching one division she's not
just nobody
she's not just some random person caught
in this town agatha is very clearly
heavily involved with what is happening
it was relatively obvious at first that
she was more than just the nosy neighbor
but episode 5 hit us right in the face
with it when she asked wanda if she
wanted to do that take again
this made it very clear that she knew
what was happening she knew
wanda might want to do a retake she also
saw the twins grow up and said nothing
as it didn't shock her at
all she is involved with what is
happening somehow now it's no
coincidence that a witch was just stuck
in the radius of the energy barrier that
wanda put up
she wasn't just a member of this town
that wanda has supposedly taken hostage
she's there for a very specific reason
and i believe that agatha
being a witch of possibly thousands of
years old and one
truly experienced in witchcraft and
hexes i believe that she is the one who
brought vision back to life and not
wanda
i believe that wanda tried to bring
vision back to life but couldn't because
she couldn't bring
the mind stone back this is proven by my
second main point
and that is that we have literally seen
the mind stone in one division teasers
and we've seen it breaking
[Music]
this is why i think that wanda could not
actually revive vision
if you think about it vision is an
android he was made he doesn't have a
soul
the mind stone is sort of what gave him
a soul and it most certainly powered him
but the mind stone is something created
by the big bang of the universe
it's not something that wanda could just
recreate you just can't recreate an
infinity stone
by the dawn of the universe there was
nothing
then boom big bangs and
six elemental crystals hurtling across
the virgin universe these infinity
stones
each control an essential aspect of
existence
space reality
power soul
mind
and time
[Music]
the energy being picked up from inside
the barrier is relic energy
from the big bang and again long said
relics when explaining the stone
so i believe that wanda tried to
recreate the mind stone
but failed we see this happen in one of
the trailers we
see it explode i believe that this is
the energy coming from inside the
barrier that sword is picking up
now since wanda couldn't recreate it i
believe agatha came to her
and made her a deal to bring vision back
to life and to give
wanda a perfect life and since agatha is
so experienced in witchcraft because
she's been alive for thousands of years
i believe that she could do it i believe
wanda said yes and this is why agatha
doesn't freak out to her magic
and also why wanda doesn't have a
problem performing magic in front of her
in episode 5.
because she's becoming aware that she
made a deal with her before
and this is why agatha can ask wanda if
she wants a redo in episode 5.
agatha is giving her her perfect life so
when things don't go according
to plan they do retakes now here's where
we get into
a little bit of a tricky part i don't
think that this is the real
vision not entirely at least i think
this is the missing person that jimmy wu
mentioned
the one from episode four or at least a
part of him
i think that in order to bring vision
back she might have had to take a life
from somebody else and i think that
somebody else
that missing person is wonder man and
that brings me to my third point
vision is wonder man we actually know
that wonder man or
simon williams which is his real name is
in one division
marvel actually let this one slip in a
promotional spot they were doing and you
could see wonder man in the back
now in the comics vision is built off of
the brain waves of wonder man so
it would make sense that this new vision
could be built off of wonder man
in one division as well if agatha took
his brain waves or life force to create
vision that could be his connection
and that would also bring in one of our
villains and that is my fourth main
point
the grim reaper the grim reaper in the
comics is wonder man's brother
and in the comics he wants to kill
vision because vision is an artificial
version of his brother and a mockery of
his brother
and we have actually seen an easter egg
for the grim reaper in the second
episode of one division we can see the
grim reaper's helmet
we can also see what appears to be the
grim reaper or at least
his scythe in agatha's brooch and
necklace further implying that both
agatha and the grim reaper
are villains and they may not actually
be connected because if agatha took a
part of
wonder man and made the new vision out
of him then the grim reaper isn't going
to be too happy about that and not only
will he want to kill vision
but he might go after agatha now i said
i believe wanda and agatha made a deal
what is this deal wanda made with agatha
i'm not entirely certain but
it probably has something to do with a
nightmare and
or mephisto and i'm going to kind of
combine nightmare and mephisto into
one main final point because i believe
that their characters might be fused
into one character
in one division and the mcu moving
forward but i'll start with nightmare
as we get further and further into one
division i'm starting to believe that
there are villains that have influence
on what is happening but we won't see
them for a while
maybe not even in one division and i
believe that nightmare is one of these
villains the reason that i believe this
is because of the dead vision scene and
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
originally it was stated that nightmare
was supposed to be the villain for
doctor strange
but they went with dormammu and decided
that nightmare would be the villain for
doctor strange 2 which we now know is
the multiverse of madness
and as far as we're concerned nightmares
should still be the villain of doctor
strange 2.
because scott derrickson although no
longer the director wrote a complete
script and unless sam raimi is going to
completely change this script altogether
it should still be nightmare
now we know that wanda is going to rip
open the multiverse and these events
will lead
right into doctor strange where
nightmare could be the main villain when
wanda briefly saw dead vision
i think this was nightmare creeping in
and i think we may see wanda having a
bit more tiny
nightmares as the show goes on now as i
mentioned
nightmare and mephisto might be one
character and the reason because of this
is what the devil represents to some
cultures in some cultures the devil
is very taboo and it doesn't bring good
luck and therefore they don't like it
very much and disney is well aware of
this
and this is why they may not make a
mephisto character per se
be the devil but could simply fuse him
with somebody like nightmare and could
have him be
fear or death now you know i can't
mention a video about villains of one
division without talking about mephisto
but when we first started this i
definitely thought mephisto was the
absolute villain of one division
and i still think he's behind some of
what's happening and i think agatha
works for him but i don't think he's
going to be
as involved as i thought we have however
found an
actual easter egg for him in the loki
trailer so he is definitely on his way
and i think he still wants wanda's kids
and that may be why agatha made a deal
with wanda
to eventually get her to have kids after
all everything in this reality seemed to
be made to make one to think about
children
mrs hart in the first episode asked why
they didn't have kids
the second episode showed us the for the
kids talent show that placed a
very big emphasis on for the kids and
then at the end of that episode
wanda was magically pregnant there's
also the emphasis
on jimmy wu finding out that the kids
were actually created
in the reality and are not actors then
there's agatha showing up around the
twins
all the time this could all be so
mephisto can get wanda's kids because in
the comics they are actually shards of a
soul
and this could be the master plan behind
everything now ultimately i think this
reality will end up breaking in one way
or another
whether that's wanda loosener kids or
vision or something else
and when that happens i believe doctor
strange will appear
wanted takes place before spider-man far
from home and in spider-man far from
home when peter asks
what about doctor strange nick fury or
talos
says that he's unavailable and he's most
likely unavailable because he's with
wanda and then we'll
get doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness this is what i truly believe is
happening and is going to happen in one
division
i could definitely be wrong but let me
know what you think about this theory in
the comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all
the latest mcu videos don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
me